technically most of us leave school at
18 an event that tends to be vividly
etched in memory and surrounded by
considerable ceremony and emotion and
yet rather oddly despite appearances
many of us in fact don't manage to leave
school at that point at all in a part of
our minds we may still be there deep
into adulthood
not sitting in a classroom precisely but
in terms of how our minds work as much
stuck within the confines of a
school-based worldview as if we were
showing up for assembly every day
generating immense and unnecessary
degrees of unhappiness and compromise
for ourselves in the process what might
be some of the hallmarks of an enduring
school like way of thinking first and
foremost a firm belief that those in
authority know what they're doing and
that one's task is to obey and jump
through the hoops they set for us a
desire to please teachers and gain
prizes cups and ribbons secondly a sense
that there is an implicit curriculum out
there an externally mandated map of what
one needs to do to succeed and that a
wise person must dutifully subscribe to
its demands thirdly a feeling that work
should when it's going well feel
substantially dull and somewhat
pointless schools teachers to forget or
ignore the clues offered to us by our
own boredom they teach us dangerous
degrees of patience they subtly train us
in intellectual masochism you're doing
it for somebody else an audience your
teachers and your parents and they're
substitutes in adult life make us proud
you have to shine we've given you so
much what matters is the performance not
any inner sense of satisfaction
Authority is benign they want what's
good for you and they speak on behalf of
your long-term interests don't think you
could ever know better
distrust your instincts will look after
you if you follow our rules you will
thrive the exam and all its successors
are fundamentally accurate they those
who know have worked out the ultimate
test of your value you are what you
score every school is in addition a
miniature Society equipped with a strong
sense of what values to revere and codes
to follow bullies lurk ready to mock and
identify any departures from the norm
you can't escape them they're next to
you in class every day they will spot
and persecute the weirdos they can ruin
your life you learn to cower and adjust
your attitudes following the herd is
paramount all these ways of thinking
don't require us to be sitting in a
geography class we might be in an office
selling garden furniture to the Belgian
market and thinking like this we might
have children of our own and by all
appearances be an adult and yet still be
living inside as though there were exams
to pass and cups to be won what would it
mean to break the mold what would it
mean finally to leave school
it would mean knowing some of the
following
that there is no one way no guarantee of
one set path to fulfillment laid out by
authority figures they don't know no one
knows the safe path may be entirely
dangerous to our flourishing
our boredom is a vital tool it's telling
us what's slowly killing us and
reminding us that time is monstrously
short authority is not by definition
benign the teachers and their
substitutes have no real plan for you
except insofar as it suits their own
advancement it looks like they want your
supreme good but in reality they want
you to play their game for their own
benefit at the end they have no proper
prize to offer you they'll give you a
colorful card and send you to the golf
course and a grave and have wasted your
life it doesn't matter what the bullies
think no one is normal
you can dare to make enemies indeed you
must do so as the price to pay for
having developed a character and found
something truly to believe in we
shouldn't be tough on ourselves for
lingering so long school is an immensely
impressive system we start there when
we're not much bigger than a chair for
more than a decade it's all we know it
is the outside world and that's what
those who love us most tell us that we
should respect it speaks with immense
authority not just about itself but
about life in general
it's sold to us as a preparation for the
whole of existence but of course the
main thing it does is to prepare us for
yet more school it is an education in
how to thrive within its own peculiar
rules with only a tenuous connection to
the world beyond knowing all this we
might do a very strange sounding thing
finally work up the courage to leave our
inner school be it a 28 35 or 62 and
then enter the wider boundless world
we've been in flight from for too long
at the school of life we believe that
confidence is a skill we can all learn
our confidence prompt cards are designed
to help us master this essential skill
click now to learn more